auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge vor einem jahr haben wir
auswanderer begleitet
patricia und romano zu die wollten aus
dem alltag ausbrechen und eröffneten auf
der insel bali ein gästehaus
doch das heimweh machte ihnen einen
strich durch die rechnung
der neustart in der schweiz ist nicht
einfach
mehr freiheit das suchte familie volk
aus dem zürcher weinland in kanada
gründeten sie erfolgreich ein holzfäller
unternehmen ihre spezialität rodungen in
steilen hang
jetzt aber macht ihnen die
einwanderungsbehörde probleme und tobias
bayer und michael paris zog es in den
sonnigen süden nach fuerteventura
die beiden hatten nur sechs wochen um
den rohbau in eine bar mit souvenir shop
zu verwandeln
wie geht es denn auswanderern heute
haben sie ihr glück gefunden
[Musik]
in kanada werden wurden träume wahr
simone fall kommt ihr sohn john genießen
den luxus der ihnen das neue leben
bietet
[Musik]
aber langsam
es ist september 2017 john ist
mittlerweile 7
seit ein paar wochen darf er auch
alleine und steuer als volks das
grundstück übernommen haben war es
komplett bewaldet mittlerweile hat
ehemann christian ein stück gerodet und
wenn man im moment in den hormonen 20
hektar ab oder blöd aber du kannst
einfach wirklich mache war david und
wenn man dauernd kühe druckstellen
stelle markiert ruf wenn man wenn ein
paar castro stellen stellt ihr drauf und
das ist schon herrlich vor zweieinhalb
jahren wagte die familie hier den
neuanfang
[Musik]
christian waren die regeln und
vorschriften in der schweizer
forstwirtschaft zu eng geworden
[Musik]
er wollte der bürokratie entfliehen und
suchte mehr platz für sich die familie
und das holz fälle unternehmen
eigentlich haben volks alles was sie
sich erträumten nur ein blatt papier
trennt sie vom happy end die dauerhafte
aufenthaltsgenehmigung für kanada haben
sie bis heute nicht erhalten
hey da hat man so viele pläne und
irgendwie in teilen hier wirklich doch
gaston bliebe dennoch mache die pläne
war nicht so wirklich spaß
der premier ist bd r bd froh steinig
wenn du mit deiner behörde und dann
zügig dass irgendein quasi auf die hand
gesetzt einmal ja
die volks kämpften von anfang an mit der
bürokratie
wir blicken noch einmal zurück auf den
beginn ihrer auswanderungs geschichte
[Musik]
zwei jahre früher in wald bei
bildschirmen im kanton schaffhausen
würden sich 30 tonnen durch das
unterholz die holzernte maschine ist das
startkapital von auswanderer christian
volk sie soll mit nach kanada
christian ist chef eines
forstunternehmens mit neun angestellten
der 40 jährige ist auf die arbeit im
steilen gelände spezialisiert es gibt
keinen baum dinner nicht fällen kann und
das ist in kanada anders
du gehst da kommt nur noch sechs wochen
bis zum abflug
das sägewerk in kanada mit dem volks
einen vertrag haben wartet bereits mit
den ersten aufträgen aber noch immer
fehlt das visum bewerben mit denen kein
visum wenn es noch war sehr lang
verzögere den helm einfach das problem
den maschinen können jetzt über die
hände raus mit handys verkaufen ergänzte
mir hän die polizei auf risiko gespielt
so und schon sieht es wie jeden
nachmittag zu seiner großmutter
großmutter wohnt gleich im nachbarhaus
[Gelächter]
john darf die eier aus dem nest holen
für ihn ist die großmutter eine wichtige
bezugsperson
doch damit ist bald schluss es war
einfach das war einfach bei möglichen
einfach können wenn wir jetzt nervt dann
hätten einfach könne durch aufmachen und
er könne sehr gegossen und so rosi rüber
und sie hätte immer freut egal wenn zu
jeder tageszeit und das war natürlich so
einfach
ich habe auch ein büro jetzt hier ja ein
umgehen der schweiz auch grenzen
simone hat eine mail aus kanada erhalten
[Musik]
gott ist alles irgendwie 1000
der antrag für das visum ist geplatzt
das vorstelle dass das da passiert das
ist jetzt einfach unmöglich genau das
erfüllt was event mir dringend eine
kapitalmehrheit der firma mir schaffet
viel arbeitsplätze hände innovative
technik wo sie darüber gar nicht kennen
aber unbedingt buch hat mir hän verträgt
und wir wissen einfach nicht was jetzt
dort angepasst
[Musik]
volks haben alles auf eine karte gesetzt
sie haben ihre wohnung geräumt die firma
verkauft und die geschäftsleitung
abgegeben
[Musik]
meine sich die ganze existenzen der
maschine kauft nur für das ist doch
genau denken
ja furchtbar ich meine da kann man jetzt
das sind doch mega blauäugig dass die
das also schon verkauft und auch wenn es
nach diesem handy ja wie blöd sich mal
eigentlich aber aus bremischer
deutsch-deutsches einzig sie von ganze
projekt oder einkauf und das sägewerk
bei handys wähler und die entweder dass
man auf hat aber du hast hier
normalisiert etwa der athletisch hat den
griechisch tochter und um und schoss das
herren- und dann unverhofft der musik
schritten dem motto online status of
your application have changed refused
ist replaced by somit looks good
wahnsinn da
warum die einwanderungsbehörde ihren
antrag nun doch noch bewilligt hat
bleibt unklar
[Musik]
freud für ihn ist aber im gleichen
moment ist ein termin den haag orders
nur effektiv wirken und das hat meine
gemerkt so richtig für familie volk geht
es endlich los
der flieger nach kanada hebt ihn zwei
stunden ab
[Musik]
zum check-in kommt mitarbeiter mirco als
letzter auch er wandert nun aus
die letzten minuten auf schweizer boden
[Musik]
zu haben zu viel raum
wir führen
die welt ist nicht mehr heraus gilt doch
gerade dort
[Musik]
mein vater war und eigentlich nie aber
das sehe das ist furchtbar
ja das war schlimm da hat man einfach
sehen was man ihnen wird man dadurch
immer größer
geld bekommt und seine scheiben druck
sind
[Musik]
ein einkaufszentrum im touristenort
corralejo im august 2017 bereiten tobias
bayer und lebensgefährte michael paris
wie jeden tag die bar für gäste vor
neben cocktails softdrinks und kaffee
verkaufen die beiden auch kleidung und
souvenirs mit ihrem logo es ist
hochsaison auf den kanarischen inseln
sind so viele touristen wie lange nicht
tobias und michael sind seit 13 jahren
ein paar
im frühjahr 2016 packten sie ihr projekt
gemeinsam an
sie hatten einen fixen plan wenig geld
und null erfahrung in der gastronomie
und die ersthelfer sich geflüchtet das
ist aber jedem gast
als chef im eigenen geschäft müssen sie
ihren alltag immer wieder neu
organisieren
wir arbeiten nach wie vor 120 hier im
laden und naja vielleicht merkt 14
stunden am tag hier oder zwölf stunden
sollen den alltag aussagen man es macht
und wir haben wieder einmal zur stelle
sich aber schon vier stunden
das ist schon mal gut
schon im frühjahr 2016 michael paris
absolviert seine letzten tage als
stellvertretender geschäftsführer in
einem bekleidungsgeschäft er kommt aus
ungarn und ist seinem partner tobias vor
zehn jahren nach bern gefolgt
statt kleidung wie michael wald
cocktails in der eigenen wahl verkaufen
den pachtvertrag für das lokal haben die
beiden bereits in der tasche
die stars sind mit dem namens alles
zusammen was musst du dich führen wie
ein star
nach wiegen werden gebeten sich mit die
sicherheitskontrolle in die abflug seine
zu begeben
ground service agent tobias beier zwei
tage pro woche kümmert er sich in bern
belpmoos und das wohl der passagiere
die restliche zeit ist der
sachbearbeiter in einem verlag
schon seit seiner jugend träumt der 46
jährige vom auswandern und einem leben
an der sonne
das geht sonst
wohlen bei bern ein samstagmorgen 6 uhr
früh für tobias und michael ist der tag
der abreise endlich da die letzten
monate sind die beiden bei tobias eltern
untergekommen
ihre eigentumswohnung haben sie bereits
vermietet werden das budget für das
auswandern ist bescheiden rund 30000
franken nur das nötigste haben tobias
und michael dabei kleidung eine
kaffeemaschine und musik cds für die
bahn
das ist alles was sie aus der schweiz in
ihr abenteuer mitnehmen
auf vier rädern nach fuerteventura
rund 3500 kilometer liegen vor den
beiden und ihrem alten auto
vorfeld immer schön und jetzt machen wir
sind gespannt wo das kind was es ist ein
gutteil der moment der sicherheit
das ist für mich das wahnsinnig sie das
kühler die unsicherheit schaffen wir das
und kommen vor lauter
ein ferienort an der nordspitze der
insel wird die neue heimat
herausforderer
die stadt coria der glockenturm campana
rio ist ein shopping center weg vom meer
und vom touristenzentrum dort wohnen
tobias und michael weber eröffnen
bereits vor zwei monaten haben sie einen
architekten beauftragt mit dem umbau
ihres lokals zu beginnen
und jetzt da
sie wollen so schnell wie möglich gäste
bewirten
also das geld nicht zu uns der ganze
auch war da schon mal produktionsfirma
das futter und machen sie
auch das waren wir nicht vorbereitet ich
denke dass da wirkt das alles
jeder hat wird uns ich weiß nicht die
sterne vom himmel versprochen und
nachher kommst du kommst du hier am und
hast deine verrücktes lokal war wurde
man noch keine einzige minute erster ort
termin mit der architektin
auf 50 quadratmetern wollen sie ihren
gemeinsamen traum verwirklichen sind
noch unsicher wegen des souvenirshops
dieser bereich ist 3 auf 3 meter groß
aber wir können ihn auch größer machen
drei meter und 10 für die es wäre gut
sieben meter für die bark zu haben
ich möchte das gern mal ab stars
fuerteventura der name der bar steht
schon lange fest und auch die
einrichtung haben die beiden schon genau
vor augen
die bar ist nicht das einzige problem
michaela und tobias wurden geld sparen
und so schnell wie möglich raus aus
ihrem teuren ferienappartement dass sie
für den anfang gemietet haben
sie klappern verschiedene maklerbüros ab
auf der suche nach einer günstigen und
schönen wohnung
das erste angebot liegt ihm wenig
gepflegten zentrum von corralejo
du fährst musst du dich hoch
waschmaschine ist ja ganz klar
[Musik]
ja ich glaube
die besichtigungen fällt kurz aus ich
bin als alter hut aber dass das dann
auch 1 gemeint also ich will ich hätte
wohl nie gemüt
[Musik]
da wäre noch die geschichte des ehepaars
trudi ihren traum von einem leben auf
der ferieninsel bali haben romane und
patricia nicht einmal ein jahr lang
gelebt im neuen alten zuhause in kesswil
blicken wir zurück
und liegt im herzen der insel bali hier
wollen sich zu dies mit einem kleinen
gästehaus eine neue existenz aufbauen
im januar 2016 ist romano alleine nach
bali vorausgereist seine frau patricia
ist noch einige wochen an ihren
arbeitsvertrag gebunden
startreihe was ein super wochenende
haben so das überleben in der schweiz
ist ehefrau patricia auf dem weg ins
büro
sie ist bereichsleiterin soll bei einem
deutschen grossverteilern am hauptsitz
in weinfelden führt sie ein team von
acht mitarbeitern bald wechselt sie ins
bett in breakfast unter palmen auf der
insel bali packt romano das neue leben
für sich und patricia zum ersten mal als
chef des eigenen bed and breakfast
moody's haben den vermieter frank über
das internet gefunden
vor sechs monaten sind sie nach bali
gereist um verschiedene objekte
anzuschauen
unter anderem dieses gästehaus für das
haus mit drei zimmern bezahlen sie rund
750 franken miete pro monat
die räume sind dreckig und das mobiliar
in einem schlechten zustand
das kommt von der insel kos wurden
dachpfannen der rechte dank natürlich
mein beruf wurde ist offen wie zu geholt
das ist wirklich spezieller wann sie
will jetzt natürlich anders
in der ricoh und das ist erst wieder
erschossen
irgendwie objekte so und dann zu
verstehen
[Musik]
moody's haben das haus zuerst für acht
monate gewartet
testweise danach wollen sie den vertrag
neu aushandeln
[Musik]
basel zwei wochen zuvor noch wissen
studis nicht was sie auf bali erwarten
wird patricia und romano hatten freunde
und kollegen eingeladen beim
abschiedsfest stellen sie ihre pläne vor
einziger wermutstropfen tochter natascha
kommt nicht mit dank für uns schließlich
sind 25 leute gekommen um mit ihnen zu
feiern
das salz bestimmt haben es auch bei
stelle aber anscheinend ist doch
irgendwie sexy von community für lothar
dass es außer dem fahrer hast du gemerkt
im nachhinein aber wenn wir nochmal zeit
immer wieder ja die 11.500 als grußwort
kilometer hat man vielleicht sagt der
hellhörigen sie als zugangspunkt aber
ich denke wenn wir jetzt hellhörig sie
war es war sicher nicht mangelt
[Musik]
tschüss
sie hat uns nie gegen webseite in einer
kurzen ton so für sie schafft auch
hauptsache es geht uns gut
oder dass ich schon und ich danke da man
jetzt wo man steht am flughafen eine
therapie wusste sie ja heute ist's
möglich sei
[Musik]
das neue zuhause von familie volk liegt
am rande der rocky mountains 4000
einwohner leben hier weit verstreut
zwischen den bergen
heute übernehmen volks ihr neues haus
sie haben es noch von der schweiz aus
gekauft
[Musik]
stimmen werben
das neue heim ist 450 quadratmeter groß
und hat sechs zimmer richtig steil knapp
500000 franken hat familie volk für das
haus bezahlt
im verkaufspreis ist auch schon die
outdoor ausrüstung enthalten ein wort
und ein motorboot und dann immer sage
ich dann entschieden zum witz mehr geld
fürs losgehen und schlussendlich nicht
dass eigentlich die besten teuer und wo
man hätte könne mache werde ja da ist wo
das paar das traum dort fließen bei
familie volk heißt es in ihrem wald 65
hektar gehören ihnen ein schatz für
christian
[Musik]
rust druck war passiert weil handys
gebiet im abwasser in cannon falls im
heizungsraum so schieße so
[Musik]
ganztag ist so komisch gipfelt im ganzen
haus und der mensch denkt ich muss das
jetzt so sie und den chor steht das
remis und es ist wirklich so höre ich
jetzt was hat ihnen gestanden das muss
jetzt also gar nicht zu denken geben
muss selber aber so sagt ritter
[Musik]
hier haben christian und sein
mitarbeiter mirko vor kurzem den
wohnwagen an die abwasserleitung
angeschlossen was krieg sei aber ich
weiß dass ich jetzt die scheiße die oft
weg putze mir hat er sich luft sowie
dadurch steckt um mehr casinos inc trade
and du bist das papier setzt auf
nachspüren
die fein kurzarbeit habe ich gemacht sie
steht voll in der scheiße die will ich
nicht mehr
[Musik]
im zentrum von corralejo haben tobias
bayer und michael paris nach langem
suchen eine wohnung gefunden
der besitzer hat ihnen das möblierte
vier zimmer appartement für ein jahr
über lassen
sie nutzen jede freie minute um sich
hier wohnlich einzurichten
da die indische familie gewohnt zwölf
jahre lang als 2000 mit trend und trikot
und trinken sie angeben
das ist das echte spektor
tilgungszuschuss plötzlich ein etwa 15
meter ist ein bisschen so wie offiziell
auch und ich nehme heute berater die
bauarbeiten in ihrer bar email kampagnen
haben endlich begonnen
[Musik]
sechs wochen später als geplant
wie geht's ihnen bestens die auswanderer
sind mit ihrem bauführer silvio
verabredet er hat den auftrag übernommen
und soll dafür sorgen dass die
handwerker pünktlich fertig werden und
sorgfältig arbeiten dass da ist für die
discokugel aber es ist nicht im zentrum
ja das ist für die kugel die kette ist
nicht in der mitte
in der mitte ja ja dann hängen wir sie
um seine vorteile wo man sagt ja immer
noch größte muss auf der straße und das
paar wortwechsel die maschinen darf ich
habe diese kostet das ist ja so und es
hat eine mit werken möchte findet
zwischen hat doch bestimmt sie und
schulterklopfen auch nochmal mit
beschafft und die heißt es nerven platz
kam tobias und michael müssen immer
wieder aufs neue druck machen
sie haben abermals einen termin mit
ihrem bauführer vereinbart
der geplante eröffnungstag rückt immer
näher
das ist dagegen dialekt das heißt also
wenn ich zusammen mit eröffnung erster
juni wird es da schon wieder hat der
mitarbeiter und da muss ich nicht
verhindert die auswanderer wollen
erreichen dass die bauarbeiten vier tage
früher fertig sind tobias muss jetzt den
chef markieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich gehe davon aus dass in einer woche
alles fertig ist
so hätten wir zwei drei tage mehr zeit
die möbel und die flaschen einschäumen
und zu reinigen
die eröffnung ist am freitag den 27 in
schwarzach locker her größte seit zwei
wochen vorläufig dänischen
öffnungstermin markus dass man selbst
sich später in der woche sagen wir so es
mehr ausgestellt denn es ist das
kommuniziert gegen die rechnung machen
kein problem
ihr könnt mit dem 27 rechnen das
gespräch verlief besser als erwartet
ok ja
[Musik]
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle besser
email campana rio steht die nächste
baustellenbesichtigung an tobias und
michael wollen sehen ob sie sich auf
ihren bauführer verlassen können
und siehe da der elektriker hat schon
angefangen
ich denke der nächste
wir gehen unsere investition war schon
greifbar sein ich weiß unterschieden
geprüft wird jetzt aber irgendwie ihrem
schicksal
es ist ein schwarz-grünes langsam in die
wand seehofer zwar höher doch da man das
touristenlokal musste irgendwie mal
vorstellen wieso seid square anschluss
auf der insel bali renoviert romano
trudi das gästehaus alleine ohne seine
frau patricia die kommt aber bald nach
heute gibt er den umbau den letzten
schliff
in seinem neuen leben blüht romano auf
voller vorfreude ließ er die gästezimmer
streichen betten nachttische und
kommoden hat er nach seinen wünschen
anfertigen lassen
[Musik]
dann endlich nach sieben wochen trennung
können sich romane und patricia wieder
in die arme schließen
patricia empfangen hier tropischen 30
grad nachdem sie die schweiz an einem
kalten winterabend verlassen hat
[Gelächter]
der nächste morgen patricia will jetzt
das gästehaus hin dass mehr als erstes
auffallen ist es ist utopisch
meine tricks holen oder sagt was zu zwei
chancen durch rostschutz den gedroht
wenn auch vom flog auf ja aber wenn sie
erzwangen bis quarks co mit einem motor
scooter für mir der marke stihl
er hat das mit 45 8
[Musik]
romano zeigt patricia das haus das er
mit viel herzblut renoviert hat doch die
schlanke weiße blitz gross findet es
okay ich mir gar nicht bewusst dass ihre
so negativ und die luchse ich mag mir
schon problem wenn sie gar nicht da sind
teilweise vorteil da sie nur es aber mit
uns ergänzt er auf zwei oder tod und du
sagst dass er früher
patricius vorahnung sollte sich
bestätigen
seit vier wochen haben schuldig die
zimmer auf einem online marktplatz für
privatunterkünfte inseriert durch
gestern blieben bisher aus
[Musik]
das ist stark was patricia und romano
benötigen wäre der zugang zu einer
großen internationalen buchungsplattform
aber das ist nur möglich mit der
offiziellen lizenz für gästehäuser diese
immer noch nicht bekommen haben
um nicht ganz auf der stelle zu treten
haben die beiden flyer entworfen
jetzt so langsam mal verloren das mit
großer bis falsch gemacht haben nicht
geglaubt
danke hamit altintop
die erste rückkehr im sommer 2016 ist
geplant
dies sind für zwei wochen zu besuch
mutter rosmarie hat für tochter patricia
und schwiegersohn romano 1 morger
zubereitet natürlich gibt das gästehaus
auf bali zu reden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
auch tochter natascha kommt vorbei sie
hat sich extra freigenommen
[Musik]
ja
fast vier monate konnte patricia ihre
tochter nicht in die arme schließen eine
lange zeit für beide wo in die richtig
konto
[Musik]
seit fünf monaten lebt familie volk
bereits in kanada
es ist winter geworden die kurzen tage
und die kälte drücken auf die stimmung
simone hat sich mit einem heizstrahler
an ihren schreibtisch verzogen
wie schon in der schweiz kümmert sich
die 38-jährige um die buchhaltung der
firma
bis christian abends wieder kommt ist
sie alleine
davon kann ich ziemlich ein willkommener
eine zeit lang also bitte also krieg
sagt also wenn da so lieb denn beliebig
mit dem land denn dann wird sich wieder
heim co aber mir geht's auch viel besser
sieht der hund hat vivendi gehalten
[Musik]
heimweh dass ich so blöd audi rational
stéphanie sich nur auf eine sache wo du
eigentlich genau weiß ihr des spiels ist
hätte ich das ist völliger blödsinn
rynair selber ärgert dass ich da wie
sondern mit blödel 867 und und und eine
schier gar nicht wo sie kommen nicht mal
seine regale warum ist eine verbesserung
[Musik]
ehemann christian gefällt die arbeit in
der kanadischen wildnis
er fühlt sich rundum wohl die familie
aber kollege ds bier ist das viel
extremer
ich habe meinen körper stolper reden
aber irgendwie war ich ja doch nicht
wahr sein das ist eine emotionale sache
andere also definitiv und witzig und da
an grenzen
doch dein kommentar über macht und eine
neue stelle ich es wirklich und will den
hof
was wissen wir pflügen die beziehung der
volks hat die wogen der auswanderung gut
überstanden und auch schon hat die neue
heimat für sich erobert william ist
chance bester freund und geht in
dieselbe klasse auch er wohnt in
clearwater aber eineinhalb stunden mit
dem auto entfernt
deshalb hat sie wohne ein playback tat
gemacht
[Musik]
christian hat einen termin mit seinem
auftraggeber der mann vom sägewerk wie
sehen ob sich der hang mit der spezial
aus richtung wirklich erschließen ist
schwierig gemacht für die heiklen
einsätze ist merkur der chef pilot
christian ist froh ihn an seiner seite
zu haben
bis zu 60 prozent gefälle sollte die
sicherung mit dem stahlseil aushalten
[Musik]
christian hat die seilwinde bis 85
prozent gefälle getestet einmal ist das
seil gerissen
es ist eine andere dkb schweiz es ist
einfach das ist einfach immer war das
ist dunkel es ist ein extrem facetime
noch ein ebit im winter bis -3 grad sind
härtere bedingungen aber ich kann tagen
ist wieder zurück fürs schaffen also
wichtig nehmen müssen zurückgetreten
christian und seine familie sind in
kanada angekommen aber dürfen sie
tatsächlich hier bleiben oder müssen sie
womöglich zurück in die schweiz
[Musik]
auf fuerteventura ist der große tag
endlich da pünktlich auf die minute
öffnet tobias bayer und michael paris
die türen zum star
[Musik]
alles ist fertig und das budget
aufgebraucht
ja beide seiten sonst das heißt so
vielleicht rollt das ab oder jemand
stolpert
da haben wir schon der erste
versicherungsfall
ab jetzt müssen sie geld verdienen
kurz ein bisschen zu kurz gegriffen
gratuliere
[Musik]
deswegen wissen wie stark sie die
bauarbeiten abgeschlossen geschaffen und
janna ist zweite phase arbeit und die
entscheidung
lauftrainer verbleiben unternehmen
hinter sich
sie sehen die ersten gäste
tobias und michael versuchen sich ab
jetzt in ihren neuen rollen
sie haben an alles gedacht
an fast alles was fehlt ist zerstoßenes
1 die cocktails heute gehämmert und
nicht gerecht
crestor
[Musik]
ich weiß sehr gestresst aber
wahrscheinlich schon das gift also alles
das man nicht jeden tag die eigene lager
der bahn also ich würde jederzeit wieder
machen
[Musik]
auf bali scheinen die anfänglichen
schwierigkeiten überwunden sei
dies rückkehr aus der schweiz war das
gästehaus über mehrere wochen ausgebucht
und doch dies geben auf bäckerin sarah
ich der letzte gast
[Musik]
die sehnsucht nach ihrer tochter
natascha war zu groß für romano aber
platzt ein lebenstraum
[Musik]
pauschales vor
jetzt reist auch beck bäckerin sarah
gekommen
ja das war's
[Musik]
nö
jetzt immer den hai e
das ist eher etwas für sauer xiii wie
jetzt der not denn mit hintergrund das
sind auch drei rolle hat das erdbeben
war dass ich wohl fühlte dass ich dann
das gefühl und emotion aber ja schon
schwierig sie sind ja so einfach sicher
nicht ganz entscheiden ob die familie
ist einfach unsere drei und wenn es
vereint die verwaltende nicht stimmten
ich bin so gestrickt dass ich einfach
sorge gut in gang
nach nur acht monaten auf bali kamen
true dies wieder zurück in die schweiz
wie erging es ihnen mit dem neuanfang in
der alten heimat
herbst 2017 tagwacht in kanada christian
volk check die wettervorhersage seit
monaten hatte es in der provinz british
columbia nicht geregnet unweit stehen
riesige waldflächen in flammen und die
gefahr neuer brände ist extrem hoch
in der dritten stufe 4 level und jetzt
nachträglich schemmelmann abgestellt
besser trocken ist jetzt seit 1018
[Gelächter]
anständige schuhe christian steht unter
druck wenn die maschinen stillstehen
verdient er kein geld
und auch seine mitarbeiter müsste er
dann ohne lohn nach hause schicken
um 7 uhr 30 muss schon zur schule
er besucht mittlerweile die zweite
klasse inzwischen gehören auch zehn
hühner und ein hahn zur familie mache
und ich weiß jetzt events pressezensur
weil noch kein motto steht das macht ihn
glücklich
[Musik]
die ein kilometer lange strecke zum
schulbus gehen die beiden immer zu fuß
und jackson begleitet sie oder gianna
meister vor cesar mich so wenig örtlich
wurden schulen und das eigentlich immer
schön die fast gern vor allem als wir es
hier mit dem auto führer fahrer john hat
eine lange fahrt vor sich volks wohnen
rund 45 minuten von der schule entfernt
geboren in der kreide
[Musik]
kaum im wald hat christian schon das
nächste problem wenn das kabel und
adapter ist praktikantin aus graubünden
braucht hilfe
[Musik]
die elektronik des vorwurfs zeigt einen
fehler
ohne die maschine kann das holz nicht
zur straße transportiert werden
also wenn ich die leute sehen so was sie
sich textilien
also ein messfehler an der schaltung ist
effekt morgen wird christian dieses teil
austauschen
ich sage ich zum einsatzleiter und
mechanik reagiert ja das war schon
wahnsinnig happy dass ich da wo man alle
typischen wo man geht zum selber fahren
maschine wieder eine riesige gebiet aber
regen einsetzt größeren ist das denn
immer nicht passt wir sind das neue ob
er noch an das ist stossend nicht parat
und nach arnheim vita 34 tage verlage
bis wieder vollgelaufen und 14 tage
immer geil
[Musik]
was christian aber vor allem fehlt ist
planungssicherheit
volks haben drei verschiedene anträge
für die dauerhafte
aufenthaltsbewilligung in kanada
gestellt ein antrag wurde bereits
abgelehnt
zwei sind noch offen
die anrufer geld im ring stehen und alle
darsteller sind einfach nicht dass das
tor blieben
problem ich definitiv dass mir nicht 08
15 sind wenn du ihr hund als arbeiter in
den us-werken unterstütze ich das zu dem
ex präsent wie bewerber
foto provinz machen und physisches
problem dass mir redet von der firma
sind sie mir also selbstständig das
passt nicht einfachen schema hoffen und
abwarten
vielmehr können die volks momentan nicht
tun
[Musik]
in kesswil kann sich romano seine zeit
weitgehend selbst einteilen
seit der rückkehr in den kanton thurgau
ist er selbstständig und verkauft
kunsthandwerk dass er aus bali
mitgebracht hat mehrmals pro monat
bietet er seine waren auf verschiedenen
märkten in der deutschschweiz an
barth laufe unterschiedlich noch
ersetzte umrisse annette so wahnsinnig
und wenn es weiter denn je nach dem
seitenwechsel juli und dann hätte sich
das heutige drogen druck gut laufen
ich glaube die aber immer noch nur
satire musik angeht seines onkels
traktiert nicht in eine region haben
erfahrung gesammelt
in sichtweite der grenzstation in
kreuzlingen befindet sich das büro von
ehefrau patricia aber denn kritik zu
lasch es geben sollte jetzt soll einfach
nur die 57 jährige hat noch von bali aus
ihr geschäftliches netzwerk kontaktiert
und sich nach arbeit umgesehen 50
schwierigkeiten finden dass ich sicher
nicht
also 50 unter doch kunden also bin ich
froh seit märz 2017 hat patricia wieder
eine stelle mit viel verantwortung
sie ist geschäftsführerin einer
spedition und führte ein team von 22
mitarbeitern an drei standorten
ich danke dass ich vielleicht auch bis
wohin pauli niedersachse ist also sicher
roman ob seo oder wo eigentlich oder das
kann man sagen man hätte die ganze
zimmer die thermengäste pc einfach wie
soll ich sagen bin ich so engagiert
seminar und die dank der schritt ist
richtig sie für mich bin überzeugt
von markt zu markt tingeln füllt romano
nicht aus deshalb hat er vor ein paar
wochen noch einen job angenommen
der 51 jährige arbeitet nun zusätzlich
teilzeit in einem laden für tierbedarf
eine autostunde von zu hause entfernt
nicht jeder darf
da war ich auf dem prinzip buch und euro
stehe aber der highschool beschnitt voll
im trockenen
[Musik]
vom tropenparadies ins gewerbegebiet von
rickenbach bei wil
hallo zusammen
[Musik]
romano hat bisher nur einen befristeten
vertrag abgeschlossen etwas freiheit
will er sich noch bewahren
[Musik]
fahren redest das bild aber jetzt muss
einfach so regeln dass man die allianz
halte in der ferienzeit irgendwo eine
gute zeit werde ich bin immer da wo ich
weiß es ja auch jetzt sind ich weiß wo
ich in 54 hobby das ist auch gut so
kommen hier wird sagen und das macht es
für mich keine option
die nächsten stunden muss romano
preisschilder für aktionsangebote
vorbereiten
ich sag jetzt mal zwei tage in der woche
ist umstellungen sind so geholt und er
will sie sind da wirklich sind kult ruf
von dem her ist es also nicht so
schrieben unterschied ist ganz klar
so setzte mehr aufeinander steigen
[Musik]
auf fuerteventura fühlt sich das
einkaufszentrum langsam mit touristen
michael und tobias haben bereits einige
stammgäste den großteil ihres geschäfts
machen sie aber mit laufkundschaft
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was das sortiment anbelangt überlässt
michael nichts dem zufall
jetzt kann er von seiner erfahrung im
detailhandel profitieren und seine
leidenschaft ausleben von ihm wird ein
wunsch von mir sein eigenes geschäft zu
haben
ich habe nicht gedacht nicht gewusst
dass ich werde das haben aber ich habe
immer gehofft und jetzt meine hoffnung
das geschäft läuft so gut dass tobias
und michael nun zwei angestellte haben
etwa udo und dessen freundin noemi
eduardo haben sie über ein stellenportal
im internet gefunden um ihr baby zu
überlassen
viel den auswanderern nicht leicht
gemacht dass ähnliche hut so scharf wie
mir das leben hier plötzlich möchte das
riesige akzeptanz von den stammgästen
haye wird sie oft und michaela gerg mit
die integrieren das ist ok monika sie
und alle gäste genau wie schwer es ist
super das ist schön
die mitarbeiter übernehmen
tobias und michael haben ein paar
stunden pause
[Musik]
in kanada ist der himmel getrübt
rauch liegt in der luft 100 kilometer
entfernt brennt ein riesiges stück wald
eigentlich würde christian am liebsten
selbst in der maschine sitzen aber sein
erfolg hat dazu geführt dass er jetzt
mehr manager ist als holzfäller
denn für das sägewerk zählt nur die
menge christians männer müssen die enge
bis auf den letzten baum fällen das
problem die abschnitte dienen das
sägewerk zuteilt werden immer
anspruchsvoller
hallo
glaubt
[Musik]
märz steilen dass sich die box englische
sprache und wenn dir geworden war schon
immer unser wunsch den hang stellen wir
uns also wie immer geschrieben
das wird wiederum eher mentale grenze
setzen etwa wenn jetzt eine alte linke
und aussteigen
der moment der geburt nicht mehr fährt
so weiter kann die letzten bäume fällt
der notfalls von hand
an arbeit mangelt es christian im neuen
leben nicht aber geld verdienen kann er
nur wenn die teuren holzerntemaschinen
so oft wie möglich laufen
[Musik]
wenn die feuergefahr hoch ist starten
seine mitarbeiter schon mitten in der
nacht
es wird immer wieder kritik sie werden
für den eigentlich für gefahr zu groß
wird wieder schaffen und da in der regel
die gezielt haben
die letzte ladung dann ist für heute
feierabend
[Musik]
eine reihenhaussiedlung am stadtrand von
corralejo ist das neue zuhause von
tobias und seinem lebensgefährten
michael der mietvertrag für die vier
zimmer wohnung im zentrum ist abgelaufen
sie hatten ihn nur für ein jahr
abgeschlossen das wichtigste war ein
bisschen raus ausland statt also welch
ein bisschen mehr sag ich mal lust zu
haben
der andere wohnung sicher egal welche
fenster geöffnet einfach und der nächste
wand habe mir selber nicht raus gehe
dann reformen ich sehe
blauer himmel lassen wie man noch mehr
[Musik]
der neue wohnort bringt auch neue
aufgaben mit sich
ein sturm aus der sahara hat spuren
hinterlassen
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir aus dem weniger von der
letzten wochen beständig ausgabe aus
versandt
was sie da hängen
[Musik]
das erste jahr auf der insel war für die
auswanderer nicht einfach nur auf sich
gestellt mussten sie die bar zum laufen
bringen werden vom enkelab gemacht
deswegen geht prestige bringt aus so wie
man sich das vorstellt und jetzt sitze
ich jetzt das irgendwie der heimat
mein fazit man muss am eigenen seiner
alltagsarbeit machen und zum huzel
worker und das faktor jetzt haben tobias
und michael wieder mehr zeit für sich
und ihre beziehung soll ich hab auch mal
wieder raus schallte nass gemacht und
hars bord abgestürzt gleich schon
gesehen
[Musik]
flughafen heraklion es ist ferienzeit
auch für patricia und romano
das thema auswandern lässt dies nicht
los sie haben sich entschlossen ihre
vorgänger bei auf und davon zu besuchen
der triste holzer war 2014 mit ihrem
mann nach kreta ausgewandert
sonst logisch moody's und holzers haben
sich über facebook kennengelernt
persönlich getroffen haben sie sich
bisher noch nie tricks führt ein kleines
bed and breakfast ehemann marcel
betreibt eine rock und blues bar
[Musik]
das liegt am hafen von agios nikolaos
dpa von marcel buchholz ist zu einem
beliebten treffpunkt für urlauber aus
der schweiz geworden
[Musik]
nachdem moody's ihr zimmer bei tricks
bezogen haben nehmen auch sie einen
augenschein
[Applaus]
die gäste aus kesswil begrüßte chef
natürlich persönlich
[Musik]
darin sollten selbst auswanderer unter
sich moody's und holzers haben sich viel
zu erzählen
[Musik]
in kanada muss simone volk laufend für
nachschub sorgen
bis zu fünf säge ketten verschleißt eine
erntemaschine pro tag
die säge kitten haben volks in der
schweiz von einem mechaniker schleifen
lassen
in kanada ist das nun simones aufgabe
hätte nicht so ein schönes baby aber ich
bin die einzige oscar für selben helfe
sei nicht schön
[Musik]
ja da ich schaue ich bin so ganz kann
praktisch alles um musik hören oder zum
vorhaben und ja da weiß man das läuft
doch die machen wir mit schier
grenzenlos sind die waldstücke die
christians firma bewirtschaftet 22.000
kubikmeter holz müssen die männer
diesmal fällen
[Musik]
das wieder super vizepräsident abgelehnt
eine vereine zu wenig weiß
[Musik]
ja hallo wer ist denn
schon wieder eine absage langsam wird es
eng
ok hätte ich nur eine strophe
[Musik]
keine wolke am himmel kreta zeigt sich
für studis von seiner besten seite
und wo gott danken tricks
[Musik]
der wagen aber habits bäume pflanzen und
seefracht schönen konter vegetation
besser aber es ist ja so schön
[Musik]
roman und patricia verbringen eine woche
bei buchholzer im doppelzimmer mit
familienanschluss gastgeberin tricks ist
schon seit 6 uhr auf den beinen und
bereitet das frühstück vor ihr mann
massa schläft noch dass ich habe den
buchholzer sahen die sendung im internet
verfolgt natürlich gibt die rückkehr von
moody's zu reden kann auch gedacht aber
heute gezielt mit skype oder eine grüne
brücke ist dass ich so bin ich gegangen
also bin ich im prinzip auf power liegen
und bin ich da und ich sie und jetzt
träumt man skype diese termine d
hannover rück geschätzt dass ich wohl
fühlte dass ich nur samstag gar nix
wir sagen konnte dass es mit baby so
stark beschäftigen sie momentan einzige
gedanke also ich weiß nicht wer das ist
[Musik]
michael ist heute früher als sonst auf
den beinen
er prüft das angebot eines lieferanten
für die neue kleiderkollektion von stars
wäre es so aufgeteilt dass jeder hat
sein verantwortungsbereich der 42
jährige hat sein glück gleich doppelt
gefunden ist nicht nur chef im eigenen
geschäft sondern kann zum ersten mal
auch noch seine persönliche modelinie
entwerfen die t shirts lässt er nach
seinen wünschen produzieren wir haben es
eröffnet mit 30 aber nicht gewusst ob
das überhaupt jemand gefragt und
eigentlich ja jetzt da wenn wir
bestellen eigentlich immer über drei
schiffe der stücke bestellen wir also
das ja wir sind zufrieden
[Musik]
sein lebensgefährte tobias besorgt
unterdessen in der altstadt von
corralejo neue ware
je nach nachfrage lassen die auswanderer
hier kurzfristig caps mit dem stern
besticken
[Musik]
dass man sollte der größte aus dieses
unternehmen etabliert und so
funktionieren
die sprachliche roten ganz neuen und
frischen und verdanke ich das für mich
mit mit drogen frische ware newcomers
camouflage
[Musik]
mehr als 1000 t shirts haben sie seit
der eröffnung bereits verkauft
die sterne von tobias und michael
glänzen von tag zu tag heller in
clearwater weiß simone volk nicht mehr
wo ihr der kopf steht
das ist der nette briefe wie ist
irgendwas erklärt und also verschieden
man arbeitet sie zu uns verstehen und da
ein sehr for using your application
center for your interest to have shown
in kanada der satz zwischen hohem oder
der sich wirklichen hohen ja bei mir das
permanent resident nicht überholt denn
ist eigentlich die konsequenz das müsste
nächstes jahr also im ersten müssen
nächstes jahr am 18 august land wieder
verlor will das werk wie so oft es geht
die möglichkeit ins werk visa verlängere
aber vielleicht wird man das denn auch
mache aber das macht eigentlich auch nur
sinn wenn man irgendwann die chance
gesehen dass man die permanent resident
über und will wenn man wenn wir der
nicht überall mit einfach immer wieder
das werk damit verlängere sessions ein
riesenaufwand und zweitens also kann man
keine firma führen
also wenn man gesehen dass man wirklich
nicht übervoll mit dem es sich jetzt
nennt immer noch die hoffnung irgendwie
aber dann müsste man einfach sehr gemein
man die sache verkauf und geregelter
rückzug so schlimm wie sauer wer aber
wer den acker andere möglichkeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch christian lässt die absage keine
ruhe
er hat seine tour für heute abgebrochen
[Musik]
mit dem immigration bereit daran jetzt
die stunde die zeit da muss man
probieren factor wo wir vor kamloops vor
dem government office.de nach ihrer
erfahrung ist entscheidet entscheidet
na ja ich wäre schlechter witz nicht
ja ich weiß dass alle wahr machen
im rechten fuß wieder geschrieben
[Musik]
ja
auf kreta suchen romane und patricia das
glück auf zwei rädern
sie haben sich scooter gemietet
moody's haben eine turbulente zeit
hinter sich mit der hoffnung auf ein
anderes leben sind sie nach bali
aufgebrochen
doch ihr traum vom gästehaus unter
palmen hat den alltag nicht überstanden
sie kehrten in die schweiz zurück nahmen
neue jobs an und versuchten sich mit
enttäuschung zu arrangieren
seit über 30 jahren gehen patricia und
romano gemeinsam durchs leben
die erfahrungen in bali haben sie noch
enger zusammengeschweißt
die sehnsucht nach einem leben in
wärmeren gefilden ist nicht erloschen
wenn sie pensioniert sind wollen die
beiden vielleicht einen neuen anlauf
nehmen
[Musik]
sind hat mit der schritt schon nicht
wahrscheinlich schon
[Musik]
endlich regen in kanada zumindest das
für die nächsten tage ist die
feuergefahr gesunken
christian kann durchatmen das wochenende
steht vor der tür und wie jeden freitag
abend treffen sich volks mit
mitarbeitern und freunden zum
wochenausklang
[Musik]
selbst dem glück für unser kühlschrank
und soll daher ein stück macht am
friedli geschäftsführer wir unterhalten
oder wie tatsache und es wird einfach
irgendwie immer größer in kanada suchte
familie volk der freiheit für sich und
ihr unternehmen mit diesem wunsch hat
alles begonnen
voller tatendrang sind volks
ausgewandert und haben hier ein
florierendes holzfäller unternehmen
aufgebaut ohne den permanent resident
status müssen sie um die früchte ihrer
arbeit fürchten
die ironie der geschichte mitarbeiter
merkur der mit volks gemeinsam
ausgewandert ist hat seine dauerhafte
aufenthaltsbewilligung schon vor monaten
erhalten da es nervt einfach und das
recht auf und nach unten
und daher muss die behörde ja meine
politische witz auf direktive behörde
weg andere sachen und da ich was ich
jetzt halt drauf wir gewinnen ist es
vorbei und daten sind die behörden so
weit weg dass mich nehme meinen das wäre
und jetzt wo wir einfach nach
die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt
für familie volk bleibt das leben in
kanada ein großes abenteuer mit offenem
ausgang
[Musik]
einmal pro woche genießen tobias und
michael einen freien nachmittag in den
dünen des parc natural de corralejo
wirklich ganz wahr
[Musik]
stück für stück haben sie sich hier ihre
neue heimat geschaffen mit sie oft
gesprochen wurde jetzt was man heute ja
derweil nicht geschieht wird mit dem
wort geschickt
es ist vielleicht einfach bitter aber
daheim auf dem sofa das flug und das hat
jetzt so gemacht und wieder so aber das
sei ihr der mut aufzubringen alles
hinter sich
ich habe die erfahrung ist schon
unglaublich für mich
aber eine rote fahne
[Musik]
und japan
vor bald zwei jahren sind tobias und
michael mit dem auto und knappen budget
nach fuerteventura gekommen
dollar vorgeschlagen
wahrsow
dieser schritt scheint sich für die
beiden gelohnt zu haben
300 tage sonne im jahr dort leben wo
andere ferien machen und das schiff ihr
eigenes geschäft führen
das wieder machen aber ich denke das war
das wir haben im letzten moment haben
wir das geld das jetzt hier auch in sein
gutes lokal sehr schwierig zu finden was
bezahlbar ist und jetzt noch mehr leute
sind angekommen im letzten eineinhalb
jahre auf der insel
also ich denke noch mal sicher 100
schwieriger geworden
als erfolgsgeschichte ja und das ist nur
der raum
dem traum folgen so waren dann jedes
jahr viele schweizerinnen und schweizer
aus und suchen ihr glück im ausland
und wir begleiten wieder einige von
ihnen neues leben neues glück familie
henzler aus einsiedeln kaufen schwedisch
lappland eine hotel und campinganlage
vater max hoff hier seinen seelenfrieden
zu finden
[Musik]
die renovation und der betrieb fordern
den vater zu sehen
jean-marie sutter und cornelia
breitschmid verlassen ihre große familie
und wandern nach marokko aus nahe der
küstenstadt essaouira wollen sie eine
feriensiedlung bauen
doch die baubewilligung ist irgendwo in
der marokkanischen bürokratie blockiert
und wiedersehen mit der familie blumen
aus davos ihr kühner plan mit kamelen
durch das australische outback ziehen
auf einer farm trainieren sie die wilden
tiere
aber die zusammenarbeit mit den
besitzern der kamele wird für die blumes
zur ungeahnten herausforderungen
[Musik]
die neue staffel von auf und davon
am freitag 5 januar um 21 uhr auf sf1
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobile
versicherungen und vorsorge